in India where 50 student groups in New
Delhi are set to march against a
controversial citizenship law but police
say they won't allow the demonstrations
to go ahead protesters say the
legislation discriminates against
Muslims at least 25 people have been
killed across India since it was passed
in Parliament's two weeks ago let's
speak to Elizabeth bharanam in New Delhi
for is so more rallies today Elizabeth
and the protester rally in New Delhi
could be confrontational
absolutely Farley we are here in the
center of the capital New Delhi and
there is already a very large police
presence here hundreds of police
officers and there's also riot police
here in riot gear they are expecting as
you mentioned fifty students group
student groups have organized a protest
here today and what they're planning to
do is to march to the residence of the
Home Minister Amit Shah he is seen as
the architect of what critics say are
this government's anti-muslim policies
including the citizenship Amendment Act
that new legislation he has been
critical of what he says Bengali
refugees and migrants he calls them
infantry infiltrators and termites who
have to be expelled so we are expecting
a big protest today but we're also
expecting that to not be allowed folly
because the police have imposed a ban
now on no more than four people are
allowed to gather so we'll see what will
happen we know that police are preparing
to detain anyone who tries to go past a
certain point what's been the
government's response so far lays any
sign that it might be bad tracking
fadi they are not they don't look like
they're going to backtrack on this law I
mean this is a government in a prime
minister who has an image of never
backing down but what's interesting
folly is that this law is very closely
linked the government itself has linked
it to something called a National
Register of citizens and exercise which
was carried out in the northeastern
state of Assam and which the government
had said they wanted to carry out all
over the country and exercise which
requires Indians to prove their
citizenship and that is something that
the Prime Minister has backtracked on in
the past few days saying that there is
no plan to carry out this register we
know that they're under pressure these
are massive protests all over the
country and we now have 10 states so
more than half of the states in India
saying that they are not going to
implement the citizenship amendment law
and they're also not going to carry out
a national register of citizens thank
you very much for that Elizabeth
bharanam live for us in New Delhi